Два роки тому, до приходу команди Войцеха Балчуна, зробити "Укрзалізницю" прибутковою
намагалися німці. Тоді запрошений з ФРН на посаду радника міністра інфраструктури
Штефан Гофсесс 10 місяців боровся за те, щоб "Укрзалізниця" запрацювала ефективно.
Основа реформи Пивоварського та Шульмейстра, яка мені сподобалась, тоді полягала в тому, щоб
прищепити ринкові механізми Укрзалізниці.  Нині ми знаходимося там, де були два-три роки тому.
Причини цьому – політичні, вважає німецький екс-радник. Адже головний ключ до прибутковості "Укрзалізниці" полягав у тому,
щоб заробляти на вантажних перевезеннях і припинити за державний кошт фінансувати олігархів.
А відбувалося це, за словами Штефана Гофсесса, таким чином: саме різні політичні групи
були зацікавлені у дешевих вантажних перевезеннях. Тому політики не дозволяли підвищити на них ціни.
Держава шляхом дотацій покривала різницю між ціною на вантажні перевезення та реальною їх вартістю.
Перший крок мав би бути, щоб політики розрізняли дві речі: нехай держава дотує пасажирські перевезення
і відділить від них нарешті вантажні перевезення. Доки цього не станеться,
ми маємо суцільні дотації, які не мають сенсу. Політики боролися проти кожного підвищення цін на вантажні перевезення.
Окрім цього, німецький радник, що має 25-річний досвід у цій галузі, зокрема керував проектами у компанії Сіменс,
мав на меті оптимізувати роботу "Укрзалізниці". Для цього треба було об'єднати усі державні
та регіональні залізниці в одне підприємство, скоротити штат та підвищити зарплати. Але головне завдання,
з яким не впоралася ані німецька, ані польська команда – це обмежити вплив українських політиків на "Укрзалізницю".